roberge vit avec sa famille à
contrecoeur sur la rive sud de montréal
les explosions de beyrouth l'ontt
attristé et avoir appris qu'il y à du
nitrate d'ammonium ou terminal portuaire
de contrecoeur l'inquiète encore plus sa
maison est située à 5 km des
installations portuaires le fait que le
port de montréal et la compagnie yara ne
dévoile pas la quantité de nitrate
d'ammonium entreposés à contrecoeur
l'angoissent sachant pas là quand ce
trio c'est pas rassurant jeudi
on n'est pas si loin que ça on est pas
si proche non plus mais c'est ça on est
dans le nez à saissac était sécurisé en
fait les dirigeants de yara se font
rassurants leur stock de nitrate
d'ammonium sont moins élevés qu'avant
distille notamment parce que les
agriculteurs utilisent de moins en moins
ceux de sète d'engrais le service de
sécurité incendie de contrecoeur se dit
néanmoins prête à toute éventualité
on a les ressources nécessaires si
l'événement dépasse aux capacités
d'intervention immédiate
on peut avoir recours à plusieurs
services incendies autour de nous dans
un délai tout à fait raisonnable du
nitrate d'ammonium
il y en a dans tous les aéroports c'est
le cas à québec et à trois rivières le
port de montréal entrepose le sien son
terminal de contrecoeur loin du centre
ville de la métropole
impossible toutefois de connaître la
quantité qui est stocké dans chacun de
ces ports non seulement peut-elle varier
dans le temps la diffusion d'une telle
information pourrait compromettre la
sécurité des canadiens nous laisse-t-on
comprendre
ottawa sûr toutefois que la tragédie
libanaise ne pourrait pas se produire au
canada ne peut pas exprès ici mais c'est
très con maintenant pour pour savoir
exactement à ce que s'est passé mais
bien sûr nous devons ou b si il y a les
choses quand on doit faire tous les
ordres de gouvernement ont leur rôle à
jouer dans la supervision du transport
et de l'entreposage du nitrate
d'ammonium
mais les inspections pourrait être plus
systématique selon cet expert pour tout
ce qui est l'aspect transports je pense
qu'aucun problème sur l'aspect
d'inspection obligations c'est sur tout
l'aspect entreposage que probablement on
pourra voir dit certain doute rien pour
rassurer mode roberge qui sont carrément
a quitté contrecoeur les gens qu'ils y
penser à deux fois avant de vouloir
établir si ce qui est dommage ce qui est
vraiment dommage
ici jérôme l'abbé radio canada contre
cas